A year long investigation is over.
And John Durham,
the special counsel, investigating
whether there was any misconduct
by the FBI
in the Trump-Russia investigation
or just released his findings for years.
As you may recall, Donald Trump
and his supporters
pinned their hopes on the investigation
by the former U.S.
attorney for Connecticut, John Durham.
Later named special counsel
by Attorney General Bill Barr.
Trump and his allies
arguing that Durham would exonerate
him and his 2016 campaign and associates
from any hint of improper behavior.
Regarding the Russian government's
attempts to interfere
in the 2016 election.
Durham is coming
was the slogan
and the meme tweeted
by Republican lawmakers
and the president's
family hinting that Durham would lead to
bombshell indictments
of those who investigated Trump now.
The bombshell indictments did not happen.
Durham did
get one minor court
victory to court losses,
but President Trump appeared
so confident of what Durham would find,
he openly pressured
the special counsel
to release his findings
before the 2020 election.
Regardless, the report is now here.
It has dropped,
and it might not have produced everything
of what some Republicans hold for it.
Is regardless.
Devastating to the FBI and to a degree,
it does exonerate Donald Trump.
Let's bring in
CNN senior justice correspondent
Evan Perez.
Evan, what exactly did Durham find
in this report?
Well, Jake, the
bottom line
finding from John Durham's
four year investigation
is that the FBI moved
very quickly to investigate
these allegations
of connections of collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
and that they did so by ignoring
a lot of evidence
that would have led them
to drop that altogether.
He's saying that
they may have had reason to open
a preliminary investigation
and assessment.
Perhaps these are very,
very low level investigations.
But certainly what he finds is
that there wasn't enough there
to to to to support the FBI's decision
to open a full blown
investigation of this
of the Trump Russia ties back in 2016.
I'll tell you
one part of what he writes here.
He says
that it seems highly likely
that at a minimum confirmation
bias played a significant role
in the FBI's acceptance
of extraordinarily serious allegations
derived from uncorroborated information
that had not been subjected
to the typical
exacting analysis
that the FBI usually uses.
He goes on to say that the FBI discounted
or willfully ignored material information
that did not support the narrative
of a collusive relationship
between Trump of Russia and Russia.
There was a lot of very sharp criticism
here of the former FBI leadership,
James Comey and McCabe,
who were running the FBI
and who oversaw a lot of these along,
a lot of the steps
that the the report goes into, Jake.
But as you pointed out, bottom line,
there are no additional charges.
Nobody is bringing charges against Comey
or anybody else.
That the former
President Trump
kept saying he expected them to.
There was
a former Trump I'm sorry,
a former Clinton campaign outside lawyer
who was brought up on charges
he was acquitted.
Again, in here, there's a
there's a footnote that points out
there is no chargeable crimes
against people in the Clinton campaign.
Again,
something that the
the former president
said he expected this
investigation to find, Jake.
So it's very interesting.
First of all, we should note
that when President Biden took office,
he there were 22 special counsels
or one U.S.
attorney, one special counsel
that he let continue doing their job.
So one was John Durham
during this case,
and the other one was the U.S.
attorney in Delaware
investigating Hunter.
So that is why this was allowed to
proceed.
A couple
quotes here from the
from Durham's report,
one based on the review
of CROSSFIRE hurricane,
that's the investigation into Trump
and Russia
and related intelligence activities.
We conclude that the Justice Department
and FBI
failed to uphold their important mission
of strict fidelity to the law
in connection with certain events
and activities described in the report.
And he says about,
quote, certain
about regarding certain personnel
intimately involved in the matter,
there was a, quote, predisposition
to open an investigation into Trump.
He is basically saying he's these are not
criminal allegations,
but he is saying that
this was unprofessional.
And failed to meet the standards
of the Justice Department and the FBI.
Jake,
the stunning thing about this report
is that we frankly know a lot of this.
The the inspector
general of the Justice Department
did a 500 page report
that came out in late 2019
and that one
told us a lot of these findings
that Durham is now
is now confirming, frankly
one of the reasons why
Durham was brought on board
was supposedly to go beyond
what the inspector
general of the Justice Department
found in their investigation.
And one of the things
it was supposed to do
was to tell us a lot about what
the intelligence community was doing.
It turns out
they didn't find very much there
in the intelligence community.
And certainly not to support
the suspicions that they had,
that there was a cabal of of of people
from the FBI
and the intelligence community
who were out to get Donald Trump.
That appears to have fallen flat
as part of this investigation.
And so,
look, there's a lot in here
that should make
the FBI
have to come back and answer
some of the more questions,
including some of the changes
that they say
they've made to make sure
something like this never happens again.
But the bottom line
from what
we see here
at the end of a four year
investigation really
doesn't tell us a hell of a lot more
than what we knew.
You know, a couple of years ago
when the inspector
general took
a look at many of these things
and came away with 17 troubled,
very big,
troubling findings
that they said the FBI needed to fix.
Yeah.
So another thing
so Rachel Cohen, who is a spokeswoman,
the communications, rather
communications director for Mark Warner,
who is the chairman
of the Senate
Subcommittee on Intelligence,
she notes,
and this is an important
this is important context
that the Senate Intelligence Committee
spent three
and a half years
reviewing millions of documents
and interviewing hundreds of witnesses.
This is she writes
this on Twitter
and concluded
that the FBI had ample
cause for concern in 2006
And she notes that
that the committee,
the Senate Intelligence
Committee at the time
was led by Republicans.
She's referring to former North
Carolina Senator
Richard Burr and again,
both of these facts can be true.
At the same time,
it is possible
that the FBI
had legitimate cause for concern
and is also possible
that some individuals in the FBI
got ahead over their skis
and were not as professional
as they should have been. Right, exactly.
And one of the things
you come away from here in this report,
and it was surprising to me to see him
say it
because because you remember
in 2019 Durham
came out with a
very highly unusual statement
in which
he said he disagreed
with a key
finding of the inspector general
which said that you know,
there was plenty of reason
for the Justice Department, for the FBI
to investigate the Trump campaign.
He said he disagreed with that.
In today's report, Durham says that
he sees reason for the FBI
to at least take a look
at some of the initial tips
that led to what became crossed
for a hurricane.
He's saying that the FBI had reason
to investigate at least preliminary
What he doesn't see
is the reason
for a full blown investigation,
according to this report, Jake.
One of the interesting
one of the things that stood out to me,
if you remember the former president
kept saying that, you know, he
he was going to find evidence of
of of deep state spying.
Well, there is a
part here
that talks about
a confidential human source,
essentially a spy
who was tasked with going to
a Clinton campaign fundraiser
Let me repeat that.
A Clinton campaign fund raiser,
because the FBI had gotten
some information
that somebody was saying that
perhaps a foreign government
might be expecting some favors
from a future Clinton presidency.
So there you have it.
The FBI was spying
on the Clinton campaign,
according to John Durham's report.
Has the FBI responded at all
to the Durham report?
They have the
the Christopher Wray, the FBI director,
put out a statement
just a little while ago
saying that a lot of the changes
that the FBI have has made
will make sure
that things like this don't happen again.
And you know, the FBI wants to point out,
Jake, that,
you know, a lot of the leadership,
a lot of the people
who are involved in decisions
that are
that are in
for some very sharp criticism
in this report,
they're gone from the FBI. Right.
And the current FBI
director was appointed, as we as
we know,
by President Trump,
not that that has stopped him
from criticizing Christopher Wray.
Evan Perez, thank you so much.
Let's bring in former federal prosecutor
Ellie Honig and CNN's Sara Sara Murray.
So here it is, all.
300 plus pages.
Ali, the bottom line,
Durham has found that
the FBI, in his view,
should never have launched
a full blown investigation
into relationships
or allegations of relationships
between Trump
and his associates in his campaign
and the Russian government.
What's your response?
Well, Jake, there's
no surprise in that conclusion.
It was really sort
of a foregone conclusion from the start.
Let's remember
how John Durham came
to be special counsel
in the middle of 2019.
When Mueller concluded
his investigation, Donald Trump
was taking to Twitter regularly
saying all caps investigate
the investigators.
And shortly
thereafter, Bill Barr appointed
John Durham to do this investigation.
And there was a really important
and I think, revealing moment
in December of 2019
DOJ's own inspector
general came out with a finding that yes,
the FBI made several missteps
and Durham seizes
on some of these as well.
However, there was ample ground
to open an investigation.
And right away
John Durham came out
with a public statement
and said I disagree with that.
That was three and change years
ago, Jake.
So it doesn't mean Durham's
findings are valid or invalid,
but there's absolutely no surprise
that he's come out where he has.